[Música]
a esos de los 5 años sufrí abuso
infantil
después a los 10
a los 15 años
conocí a una amiga entrecomilla
consumidora de drogas y alcohol
y empecé a estar en los grupos de
consumidores
pero en ese grupo me decían que
consumiera
darle dimensión
y la verdad que no quería consumir ni ni
alcoholizado ni drogarme nada
pero me decían que estaba piola y si no
lo hacía cuando lo rechazaba que era
tonta
hasta que un día acepté porque quería
ser su amiga me emborraché pero
festejaron
las drogas empiezan a crearle depresión
a los jóvenes
empieza a romper del alma a descubrir
ese arte
a quitarte los sueños
y jamás imaginé que iba a hacer tantas
cosas malas como la que me pasaron y
pude experimentar nuevamente en ese
mundo fui
abusada
y nada bueno experimenté
después me fue cambiando la personalidad
me peleaba con mamá
era muy agresiva
en la escuela me portaba mal siempre era
la que se creía viva porque se drogaba
porque así se sienten los chicos en las
escuelas se creen los vivos nos creemos
los vivos
y muchas veces molestamos a aquel
adolescente que gracias a dios es sano
no consume
intenta dejar varias veces
hasta qué
también me mataron a las drogas me
quitaron a mi amiga éramos dos que esta
charla no quiere como ella se puede
recuperar que esta charla quede como que
no sabemos que nos va a pasar si hoy
estoy con vida pues gracias a dios y a
la oportunidad que se me presento
pero a mi amiga en una fiesta de droga
40 tipos todos grandes
la mataron
después caí en una red de trata a los 19
años que me encontraba en situación de
calle en comodoro rivadavia
me dijeron que me iban a dar buena droga
a mí me engañaron con eso a otras chicas
las engañan con otras cosas
creo que estuve como dos semanas no
recuerdo bien encerrada en ese lugar la
verdad fue horrible
no podía irme
me quise escapar y descubrieron que me
estaba por escapar
al ver al cielo con un arma en el living
cuando yo me quise escapar me dio más
fuerza para escaparme y esta vez no se
lo iba a decir a nadie
y en mi segundo intento si pude
escaparme
como termine de hecho a los 21 años
agarrando esquizofrenia en salud mental
perdí el conocimiento de todo y ya no
servía para para salir de joda como
dicen no
para salir a emborracharnos qué
divertido terminar en la casa de
cualquier tipo las chicas los varones
de pinta robar matar mira que la droga
mira qué piola que es la droga que
termine enterrando a mi amiga
y el que la mató también consumidor se
transformó en un asesino no pero es
piola
mentira
es mentira eso
y terminen como les dije en salud mental
con esquizofrenia fuerte
no no no no tenía esperanza de
recuperarme
podía terminar muerta quitándome la vida
pero eso ya es el pasado vamos a dejarla
que se vaya que esto sirva solamente
para que un pibe de acá esta noche pueda
conocer la verdad de la droga esa que
nadie la cuentan
la oportunidad fue viajar a un centro de
rehabilitación
a los 22 años viajó a rosario
la verdad que
que no tenía mucha esperanza sabía pero
había probado tantos tratamientos me
dijeron vas a un centro ya te vas a
recuperar tenés oportunidad de vida
nuevamente bueno todo el verso que me
hizo ese chico también recuperado
y cuando llego en este lugar horrible
[Música]
no me tenía que levantar temprano
desayunar
almorzar tomar la merienda y cenar
y tenía que limpiar todo el día ocupada
estaba en el lugar
y cuando me pusieron un kilo de
chocolate porque parte de la terapia fue
producir chupetines de chocolate
a escondidas de mi encargado casi me
comí todo el kilo chocolate porque había
sido mi primera vez que probé algo tan
rico fuera del mundo de las drogas así
que con mi abstinencia porque me
quitaron la medicación y empecé a
temblar no podía producir por los
temblores que me fuese cuando te quitan
la droga empiezas a el cuerpo a
descompensarse pero para sanar
así que en cinco meses me puedo
rehabilitar en el centro
cuando salgo de ese lugar no tenía
dinero no tenía trabajo todo muy bonito
me acordé de la producción de chupetines
ya en mi ciudad
y se me chupetines me fui a una feria
ambulante y ahí estaba dando lástima
para las personas adultas porque me
veían todas encapuchadas con un plato de
bombón de chupetines después de subir el
nivel a los bombones
[Música]
pasaron siete años el emprendimiento sin
querer creció
logré crear un packaging que jamás en mi
vida pensé que iba a crear
y sobre todo con este emprendimiento me
pude encontrar con mi sueño de la niñez
aquel sueño que había perdido
más o menos los 10 años
con este proyecto pude recordar que de
niña gané un concurso en manualidades
en la escuela y me sacar una foto para
el diario nadie lo festejó porque cuando
son niños nadie te festeja
así que realmente quiero
alentar a los jóvenes a aquel que tiene
problemas de adicción es que estás a
tiempo de recuperarse porque estás
comida aún y aquel que no consume te
felicito y te admiro
muchísimas gracias por escucharme y a
los jóvenes les digo emprendan sus
sueños y que dios les bendiga
[Aplausos]